my name is Brittany I'm really glad to
see so many of you here it's it's great
that people are interested in this topic
is anyone does anyone happen to be a
lawyer hands alright one lawyer um so
I'm I'm not and that's why I wanted to
give this talk today technology to me
has always been about problem-solving
within systems and our lives in this
country are built on a justice system
that has very serious problems that I
want to believe a roomful of problem
solvers can can help today 2.3 million
people are locked up in this country
that's the number that's what's meant by
mass incarceration that's out of a
population of 250 million adults for
context the imprisonment rate was stable
for the first three quarters of the 20th
century even as the population tripled
then there was an almost 10x increase in
those stable rates during the past 40
years this can't be explained by a
change in crime rates just getting that
out of the way seventy three point five
million people have some kind of
criminal record in the u.s. this is
significant because state control
doesn't totally end when you're out of
prison a criminal record also does not
only contain convictions
you only need to get arrested to have
one a criminal record makes a lot of
things in ordinary not life harder
housing yourself or your family getting
a job applying to school
traveling basically anything that
requires an ID or paperwork which brings
us here twenty nine point five percent
of the of the United States adult
population has a criminal record a third
is much too high can can we all agree on
that
let's see some nods yes okay
racism even more than sheer massiveness
characterizes this system of mass
incarceration to people remember stop
and frisk in New York City couple years
ago was so eighty percent of the stops
were of black and Hispanic people
this practice was visible but not alone
in prejudice profiling by law
enforcement its visibility is what
contribute to public contributed to
public outcry these are some FBI
statistics from 2013 FBI is a government
organization so there's reason to
believe that these are conservative
estimates but as you can see white
people are 77% of the general population
and they're arrested 69 six they are 69
percent of the arrests in contrast black
people are 13 percent of the general
population and 28 percent of the arrests
in the prison population this racial
disparity is even starker there are more
than five times as many white people
than there are black people in this
country but there are more black
prisoners what is it that's for sale in
this unjust criminal legal system I'm
going to talk through three concrete
things that you can buy during the
judicial process and after each I'll
give an example of an organization that
is using technology to make justice more
accessible for people who can't afford
that item because no one should have to
these are the three things freedom
whether you're in a cell or in your
community due process the entire legal
instrument that is supposedly guaranteed
to protect your rights and your good
standing in the eyes of the law and the
country these things are all
interconnected and they're often all
sold at once or leveraged against each
other I'm going to speak about them
separately for clarity sake but just to
highlight the trade-offs freedom is
unlocked often by paying bail plea
bargains are a bargain a way to bypass
almost everything that due process
entails and a criminal record is a
permanent record a file accessible to
law enforcement and many institutions
all across the nation that makes your
cell virtually inescapable even after
you've done your time if you have a
felony conviction in certain states it
can even mean that you lose your right
to vote or to serve on a jury or to gain
access to social services that you may
need to live
pre-trial bail to define it is money set
as collateral after you're arrested and
charged with charged with a crime but
before your trial if someone else can
come pay this amount for you you can
leave jail the idea is that you'll be
incentivized to return for your court
date to get the money back
a judge is generally going to make a
call about how high pretrial bail should
be set or if it should be set according
to a few factors such as seriousness of
your crime alleged crime your prior
history your age and whatever their
impression is of you the judge only has
a few minutes with you so since the
court system is extremely overloaded
half a million people today are locked
up for no reason other than they cannot
get out on bail almost a quarter of the
people locked up on a given day or
legally innocent that's what that means
they've only been arrested and they're
supposed to be innocent until proven
guilty that's generally because they
can't afford to get out many people who
are kept in jail are significantly less
well-off than people who are released
not significantly more dangerous it's
easier to police a poor area and get
people into jail in the first place
knowing that legal resistance and
political backlash are going to be less
well-funded it's also easier to keep
people there if it's unlikely that
anyone can come up with bail or afford
to protest if no bail is set 30,000
people go through this system a day so
it bears mentioning that some people are
released on bail some people are also
released with tracking software attached
to them which we'll discuss later and
others are released on their own
recognizance which means that their
trusted to come back for the trial
here's one thing that one organization
that's doing something about this up
trust is a company that may expand the
use of recognizance release by scaling
pretrial services those are alternatives
to bail in this case text reminders
studies have shown that failure to
appear rates not coming back for your
court date go
down over 50% if a defendant is texted
before their court date you do not need
to keep someone in jail to make sure
that they come back for the trial lots
of people just need some assistance they
aren't running from responsibility they
just couldn't get off work or they
needed a ride or they have to stay with
their kids thank you the presentations
done over this is the top response this
is the top response that upthrust
reports from the people who receive
their text reminders this is extremely
telling missing from many software
solutions to problems with law
enforcement are the effects that it has
on the people who are swept into the
system not the people who operate it
this platforms accountability to the
population that they serve which is
ordinary people is an important part of
their success and its measured in those
thank yous I'm gonna read this tweet out
loud this is defense attorney my client
walked out of Riker's Island today after
a jury acquitted him of all charges he
waited in jail for his trial for three
years he lost his job and missed his
son's first three birthday simply
because he couldn't afford bail he is
not unique this is our system he is not
unique this happens to tons of people
and Rikers Island is a jail not a prison
I'll get into that in a second many
people lose their what happened to this
man is tragic beyond belief but what
happened but many people lose their jobs
or their place to sleep at night
depending what the depending on their
housing if they're in jail for just one
night so it doesn't even take three
years to seriously disrupt a person's
entire life if they have to spend some
time in jail however spending a long
time in jail is traumatizing prison is
for people who've been sentenced and has
corresponding resources like educational
programs jail is not designed to be a
long term living environment this is
reflected in high suicide rates suicide
is the leading cause of death in jail in
local jails and was more than four times
higher in detainees in jail than it was
in the general population in a 2014
study
it's another tweet in response
there are many bail projects throughout
the u.s. that raised
to bail people out abolition is an app
that uses the spare change from credit
from debit credit debit card
transactions rounding up purchase
amounts and sending the difference to
bail funds it was started by a person
with an idea and the community response
to this idea was very striking people
offered help and encouragement
immediately the original poster
responded it works today like like the
original tweet it went live in November
of last year to the applause of a
community asking questions giving
feedback and generally super excited
about it and there's a lot to be excited
about it's raised tens of thousands of
dollars and eighty five percent goes to
the national bailout collective in just
the first four months together with
other organizations they bailed out over
20 people
that's an incredible impact to generate
from thought and follow through in less
than a year on the other hand there's
plenty of technology that's having the
opposite effect one example can be found
in the New York City criminal justice
system due to a quirk in the courts
tracking software you cannot set a value
of zero in a field that records the bail
amount on a certain form so whenever
this form is necessary people are held
for $1 when the charge would otherwise
have been nothing this is their website
it's a great organization that if you
live in New York City I would highly
recommend you check out um you can't pay
your own bail so even if you have that
$1 on you you can't get out dollar bail
Brigade registers volunteers to go do
the hours long process of getting
someone out of jail by paying their
$1.00 bail takes hours yes or entire day
just to pay a single dollar for someone
to go free
they've also collected a bunch of data
and from what they've collected 96% of
the people that are let out on bail
through their efforts return for their
court date which implies that bail is
not that effective or not pointless and
before you ask or Wonder know this
cannot just be fixed by a programmer I
asked them it would require a
legislative change to update this system
plea-bargaining this is the next thing
that's up for sale your right to trial
plea bargaining is when you're charged
with a crime after arrest you can make a
deal with the prosecutor
give you a lighter sentence in exchange
for your trial this is the other great
thing about dollar Bell Brigade and the
horrifying thing about that software is
that people who stay in jail until their
court date because for example they
aren't able to pay bail usually take a
guilty plea and there's reason to
believe that many of the people who take
a guilty plea are innocent if you are
interested later you should look up an
Alford plea they let you maintain
innocence officially but still take a
punishment like you're guilty
that exists so looking at the data more
of the data that dollar bail Brigade has
collected 95 percent of their clients
trials result in either a dismissal of
all charges or something that's
basically the equivalent of a parking
ticket not something that will go on
your criminal record so the way that the
the plea bargaining will work is
something like this say for example you
are caught with a small amount of drugs
if you agree to just say you're guilty
and skip the whole trial thing they'll
charge you with ten years of probation
that means you can go home where maybe
you're the only breadwinner or the one
who does all the childcare or both but
if you want to go to trial and have a
jury possibly dismiss your charges
they'll threaten to unleash the RICO Act
on you which was specifically created to
bring down the Mafia in the 1980s and is
now used on nineteen-year-olds to put
them in jail for longer than they've
been alive this deal is incredibly hard
to resist if you couldn't afford bail or
didn't have it set because maybe they'll
let you go home if you say you plead
guilty and it can be incredibly damaging
to not be able to go home maybe you
can't afford a defense lawyer whose
caseload isn't overflowing and who can
spend as much time with you as you need
to make your strongest possible defense
there's also no oversight during this
process no need for the prosecutor to
prove that they have the evidence to
convict you at this stage if it's on the
books they can charge it that's
basically it and not many people can
afford the get to gamble on a
prosecutor's bluff the Wisconsin Supreme
Court wrote this in 1877 plea bargains
are hardly oh sorry please are hardly if
at all distinguishable in principle from
a direct sale of justice plea-bargain
started to gain traction and become
popular and documented because crime
rates rose after at the Civil War there
was anise there was even more of an
increase during Prohibition as people
routinely violated eighteenth Amendment
many people at this time recognized the
danger of plea bargaining and thought
that it might be it might result in
coercion of the innocent to plead guilty
nevertheless in 1969 it was unanimously
declared constitutional and that's
exactly what happened this was allowed
because trials were too expensive for
the increased crime rates who here knows
who they would call if they landed in
jail you have to know the number by
heart okay keep your hand raised if it's
a lawyer okay
this is an arrest support hotline called
good call they operate out of New York
City and they turn your one phone call
into many the way it works is that you
sign up for their app and store contacts
with them then if you get arrested and
your phone is confiscated you can make
one phone call to them and they will get
you a lawyer and contact your people so
that they know where you are can visit
you cover for you at work or with your
kids or come bail you out so you won't
be alone as with as with abolition up
trust this makes paying bail and getting
out a lot easier but a huge part of the
value that you get is a lawyer defense
attorneys are very overloaded with cases
and no notification from to them is
automatically triggered when you're
arrested saying I want a lawyer means
basically nothing that's what your one
phone call is for and basically none of
you were calling a lawyer it's that's
anyway that's what that's supposed to be
for get anyone quickly can be the
difference between being pressured into
a deal that you're offered by the
prosecutor and getting a fair one this
helps you it also helps your emergency
contact who's probably very stressed out
by the fact that this is happening
without having to
also deal with legal logistics and
delegating or covering for all of your
responsibilities and all of these tools
make it less likely that you will end up
with a criminal record and I'll read but
this says you know generated criminal
record is generated for law enforcement
databases once you're arrested it may be
updated as you move through the system a
criminal record is a brand that follows
you forever and usually when people are
agreeing to plead guilty to go home for
example to the children they take care
of and the job that they need to feed
themselves it is not really explained to
them what this stamp may mean in the
future it makes future arrests more
likely it makes traffic stops more
likely it increases your contact with
the police forever and then compounds it
for numbers and breakdowns on how this
increases prejudicial profiling and
police brutality against racial
minorities you can check out campaign 0
they run a website that among other
things releases reports of long obscured
crime data that they have painstakingly
collected a criminal record can also
impact your representation 6.1 million
people have had their votes taken away
by state felon disenfranchisement laws
this was true in 2016 during those
elections so ex felons often can't serve
on juries or vote and so if you think
that any of this is unfair that will
matter a lot less if you can't vote or
effect trial outcomes in Florida where a
felony conviction can result from
stealing a phone or a watch over 10% of
the population cannot vote over 20% of
the black adults in Florida cannot vote
and it is a swing state what's even
scarier is that while prisoners can't
vote they still count towards
representation but they are counted in
the populations of the areas where
they're imprisoned not the place that
they call home this means that when
someone is sent to prison voting power
is lessened in the community they've
been taken from and greater than the one
they've been moved to this is true
despite the fact that prisoners are
usually transplanted to that
jurisdiction the prisoners own
preferences are never solicited
and free people living in areas that has
large prison populations usually have
financial incentives invested in the
prison this echos the pre Civil War
practice of slave owners casting votes
equal to three fifths the vote total of
their slaves in addition to their own in
principle this is what is happening in
mostly white rural areas where most
prisons are located clear my record to
the extent that the undue burden and
injustice of criminal records is
officially recognized there exist
processes to clear - to apply for
conviction relief to clear people's
records for certain types of charges
clear my record was developed by Code
for America to automate record clearance
as much as possible with guidance from
their clients it's a website that
accepts applications for conviction
relief which it estimated five million
Californians are eligible for they've
served over six thousand Californians to
date and the numbers climbing which is
great because it's a long way to go to
five million where people are failing it
is not for a lack of individual efforts
on the part of clients and attorneys but
because the system in which they're
operating is exceedingly difficult to
navigate this is from clear my records
latest report this May their report
mentioned that many CMR clients said
that they did not receive clear
explanations about their pleas when they
were convicted they didn't know that it
might mean that they would lose their
public housing or food stamps and the
processes to get back their good
standing are complicated poorly
communicated can take years of wrong
turns and red tape to cut through and
you guessed it it costs thousands of
dollars in lawyer fees all of these
organizations solicit feedback from
users they're publicly accountable in
the case of good call it was developed
through Blue Ridge labs a civic tech
incubator that emphasizes on-the-ground
user research upthrust records and
reports the responses from the people
they're texting they're even conscious
of their users suspicions about giving
out their phone number for contact
information
a politian born on Twitter where people
immediately raise their questions Opie
was you know answering back questions
feedback and support and clear my record
was developed through Code for America
whose mission statement includes
connecting people inside and outside of
government this is the upshot main
takeaway people are fighting against
this they're using the most advanced
tools available to help and connect
people but there are other technologies
that have contributed to the current
state of the system and new uses that
are looming in particular artificial
intelligence and machine learning
relatively new fields compared to
telephones and money wiring have been
operating behind the scenes untested and
invisible helping the system absorb more
and more people this has to stop or be
changed if we want the world tomorrow to
be better than it is today
all right predictive analytics are tools
that use algorithms to make predictions
about future crime drawing their results
from analysis of past and current law
enforcement data when they're used by
courts they are called risk assessment
tools the purpose of using them is to
gain efficiency and cut costs by letting
go detainees that the tool claims are
low risk saving judges the tools for
police use are called predictive
policing algorithms and are also meant
to gain efficiency and cut costs they
operate by directing police resources to
only high crime areas instead of wasting
them on lowing low crime areas but as
we've seen the data that goes into the
algorithms is biased and incomplete part
of what makes a high crime area high
crime is the targeted policing that's
done there and this is true of high risk
individuals as well involvement in the
system begets involvement in the system
that's all historically there's also
been very little public data available
on these tools to be able to prove that
that's true today that's starting to
change again you can refer to campaigns
Eros data many many independent
collectors of data good thing
in the case okay
machine learning algorithms of the kind
predictive policing software relies upon
are designed to learn and reproduce
patterns in the data they're given
regardless of whether the data
represents what the models creators
believe or intend in the case of pred
pol which is a tool that's been in use
for years they claim that it's supposed
to eliminate bias because a human isn't
making the decisions in fact the tool
does the opposite compounding bias
because that's all the algorithm can do
compound and repeat and magnify even
though people is released its algorithm
publicly and uses only three input
parameters time place and type of crime
it still reproduces prejudice policing
patterns it targets areas for drug
enforcement where a high percentage of
the population is black much more than
it targets a similar an area with
similar estimated levels of drug use but
where most of the population is white
the drug use data that I'm referring to
comes from public health surveys where
people have very little incentive to lie
and and actually well I'll get it
earlier and then of course the data
collected from those areas directs
police to continue policing those areas
and ignoring others thus the crime data
they are working from is just policing
data it's very incomplete remains
incomplete and come and is compounded by
the heavy bias that originally
characterized the arrest data that went
into them in the first place on the
court side tools like compass and the
public safety assessment which were on
that list I had up earlier work by
bucketing people into low medium or high
risk of reoffending look the idea is
that the low risk bucket will be
released on their own recognizance but
which numbers go into which buckets is
not regulated this actually happened
with ice under the Trump in
administration they set the risk
assessment tools to put everyone
crossing the border into a high but high
risk bucket which results in automatic
detention so judges are not required to
follow the guidelines of these tools but
that is not necessarily a good thing
first of all
it's difficult to collect data on the
effectiveness or fairness of a tool if
it's not used in a consistent way second
judges humanity may prevent obviously
draconian sentences that are prescribed
by the tools um but like all humans they
carry bias from long careers in the
system they may be influenced by the
policies of the times or use the tools
as a crutch against accountability
without good data without accountability
it is very hard to know this is also why
it's important to resist the temptation
to be hopeful about the new Senate bill
ten senators okay Senate bill 10 is a
California legislation that's banning
bail by 2019 October 20 2019 and
replacing it with algorithms however
there's nothing in the new legislation
to regulate how exactly the algorithms
are going to buck it everyone could go
into the high-risk category at the
discretion of law enforcement now we'll
talk about an example of unfair bias in
these algorithms even when they aren't
set to max I'll describe a widely
reported on study done by Pro Publica on
the compass tool one of the courtside
tools and it's used in several
jurisdictions to help judges predict
which people will reoffended in two
years this is a single study result so
take it with a grain of salt but it
illustrates the kind of dangerous
precedent that we're setting today with
numbers this was a study done in Broward
County in Florida the company that made
the tool that produced these results was
called North Point and they rebranded to
equal vent at some point after the media
fallout from this but you still know
okay between 60 and 70% accuracy overall
predicting whether someone's gonna make
commit a crime round is not good imagine
if every time you went to the hospital
there was a 40% chance that the doctor
was gonna make a serious mistake what's
even worse is that this tool shows a
racial bias when it's incorrect it gives
white depent defendants the benefit of
the doubt false negatives at high rates
similar to the rates at which it gives a
misjudges black defendants is more
likely to commit future crimes than they
actually are
researchers took that day
on the compass study and compared it
with untrained humans that they found
through an online survey they what's so
funny these tools did not do better at
predicting RIA fence or didn't do much
better at predicting re offense than
random individuals crowd based pulling
on techniques using the internet randos
actually you yielded a 67 percent
accuracy which may not determine if
there's wisdom in the crowd which was
one of their goals but at least there is
as much wisdom in the crowd as there is
in these tools arguments have been made
to excuse the tools bias that it's not
possible to maximize accuracy and
control for false negatives and false
positives and that there are many
different academic measurements of
fairness but these numbers speak for
themselves and there is absolutely no
excuse the data that goes into the tools
was collected by biased humans garbage
in so the algorithms reproduce that
garbage out it's been said that it is
human to error but to err millions of
times in a second you need a computer at
their best at their best it seems like
these tools can maybe guide conditions
of probation for example man died
mandating a breathalyzer device on
someone's steering wheel if they have a
DUI but not how long or whether someone
should be in prison that is way too
risky it's easy so I'm just an engineer
I'll repeat this in a second it's easy
to get caught up in cool implementations
but it is very important to take a wider
stance at the first artificial
intelligence ethics and society
conference this February a paper was
presented that proposes automating
classification of gang-related crime a
junior co-author of that paper was asked
about the ethical implications of that
research this was his response I'm just
an engineer are you just this is not to
call out this individual but to
illustrate a pervasive and disappointing
attitude towards engineering if we
really abdicate responsibility for the
systems that we help build we are
contributing to everything that I've
been describing the future will be just
like the path
and the present New York City is
preparing to unveil a new task force on
automated decision systems in the next
few months the public transit director
in San Francisco wanted to explore
facial recognition technology in the
underground as recently as last month
but there's so much proven bias in these
systems the data is wrong it's not just
incorrect it's not just incomplete it's
unjust
if we ignore how deeply this is built
into the concrete and stones that make
up our cities by the biases of yesterday
the world will never get better this is
how the school-to-prison pipeline works
it funnels kids from extremely harsh
schools full of metal detectors and
police officers into courthouses and
jails this is in cob Hill in New York
City it's in Brooklyn the school serves
a student population 78 percent black
19% Hispanic 2 percent white 50% of the
students of disabilities 91 percent
participate in a free lunch program what
you cannot see in these statistics are
on that map is that that 2 block area is
completely swarmed by police cars
they're in every street that parked all
around there's also a huge line you can
see the courthouse and the school Cheryl
wall I hope you can see that across the
street is the detention center with a
huge line outside of it this normalizes
incarceration for these kids kids and
it's just one more efficiency in a
system that routinely trades people's
lives for money wherever it can so why
do we use these algorithms at all
ok well unsurprisingly the answer is
money the system already cost American
taxpayers 182 billion dollars per year
and it's getting bigger instead of
deciding the system is completely broken
we've gone with a more cost-effective
way to keep the keep it churning and
these algorithms are one way to do it
this is similar to how plea bargaining
was accepted because it let more people
get through the system without crushing
it we've decided to let the criminal
justice criminal legal system grow its
practices policies and customs bleeding
freely out into other parts of the
population like schools and like
people's homes
speaking of homes we're gonna talk about
electric electronic ankle monitors for a
second this is the original design of
the electronic ankle mark
monitor um it it was a way to extend
prison into the home I mentioned earlier
that some people are released from
imprisonment with a tracking device on
them electronic monitoring was intended
as a cheaper and less destructive
alternative to incarceration pretrial or
in some cases probation or parole so you
can see all these so the design
philosophy focused on the possibility of
establishing a community-based network
that would encourage members to share
the responsibility of monitoring and
giving encouragement to other members
and see these little labeled boxes or
the different members and they're all
connected centrally it was supposed to
be what they call Bluetooth AAA where
people could communicate with one
another through an interface on the
device but that's not what happened it
may look good on paper but attempts to
justify it fail completely in the faces
of the people who have actually warned
them ankle monitors have severe
psychological effects some people who've
worn them it's hard to imagine wearing
it for thirty more years it's depressing
and upsetting to imagine I mean that
much of my life monitored it feels like
a rope around my neck I can't get my
feet back on the ground you just think
about the opportunity of being home with
the people who care about you but it was
horrible living nightmare several states
allow lifetime supervision under the
ankle monitor we're in one of them right
now if you live in one of those like
Sarah there are a lot of things you can
never do again ankle monitors are only
water resistant so you can't go swimming
ever again
and taking showers in the old challenge
sometimes they need to be charged every
four hours that means that you may have
to get up in the middle of the night to
recharge it instead of getting a good
night's sleep and it's gonna take a lot
of jobs off the table anything where you
have to be on your feet or active is
going to be a challenge and all the
while these things are costing people I
mentioned that it's less costly for the
system one of the ways that this is
achieved is by making the people who
wear them pay for them a person who is
waiting for their trial or on probation
or parole trying to get housing in a job
live a normal life may have to pay them
facture between five and twenty five
dollars a day to cover the costs this is
a win for the system but not for anyone
sucked into it this person on the right
William was not even convicted he had to
exist in what he called a living
nightmare as a completely innocent
person innocent of all charges so people
may think that any alternative to
incarceration is a good thing but if
that alternative ends up being even more
widespread applied freely without any
research on the psychological effects of
these things it can be equally punitive
nevertheless electronic monitoring use
increases not because there are studies
showing that it's a fair alternative to
pretrial incarceration or that there's
any reasonable calculation to translate
a prison sentence into an ankle monitor
sentence it's increasing because the
technology exists and there's a market
for it one very large producer of these
devices is a company called bi
Incorporated part of the very
descriptive geo group they made radio
frequency cattle tracking tags and saw a
business opportunity to expand their
operation into human beings as you can
see there's been a shift away from RF
radio frequency monitoring to GPS
monitoring it used to be that you have
the thing in your in your home and then
a thing on your ankle and if you move
too far away there's an alert now it's
changing to mostly GPS monitoring this
changes the nature of it while it may
enable more freedom of movement the
surveillance is much more invasive it
can't only tell if you're in a specific
area it can tell exactly where you are
anywhere it's hard to know exactly where
it went wrong but it seems like the
original creators weren't attached to
anyone in particular they patented this
idea that implemented it and then the
people to popularize it were people who
could make money off of it that was a
group of people who were unlike the
people that the tools were wielded
against and indifferent to the suffering
that it causes it's a similar story with
weaponry this is what it means to give
enhanced technology to law enforcement
tanks bazookas and millions of dollars
in military equipment is given out
through federal grants to
local police departments every year this
particular vehicle as you can see it
belongs to State Police
what are they new tank for maybe this is
just for show or maybe it's just for
show for now and here is the most
harrowing financial incentive of
incarceration slavery is still
constitutional this is the text of the
Thirteenth Amendment neither slavery nor
involuntary servitude except as
punishment for a crime whereof the party
shall have been duly convicted shall
exist within the United States or any
place subject to their jurisdiction the
express purpose of the Constitution as
stated by James Madison one of the
original framers was to protect the
minority of the opulent from the
majority for the sake of government
stability in federal prisons some kind
of work is mandated people are paid
cents an hour
next to nothing to do factory labor for
companies like eunuch or especially
eunuch or which makes a ton of military
equipment and is run by the Bureau of
Prisons
it's not a public company this is what
prisons are for this country wasn't just
built on centuries of labor by captured
abused and unpaid people it still is so
truth complete data and human connection
makes it harder to generate financial
incentives when it comes to companies
that create predatory pain deaf
technology it's harder to continuing
unjust practice when everyone can see
like with stop and frisk as a quick
example toll-free lines are not free in
jails this doesn't seem like a big deal
until you realize that suicide hotlines
or which are usually toll-free are not
toll free in a prison or jail phone
companies that serve prisons can just
charge whatever they want basically with
impunity and this all happens invisibly
with only people who are directly
interacting with the system of
incarceration incurring the costs this
is a poster from the prison strike last
month it was extremely difficult for
reporters to get information during the
strike it's hard to get the truth about
what's going on inside unless you go
inside so one way to be helpful actually
the last talk said it very well give
your skills one way to be helpful is to
spread your knowledge both inside
doubt education about computers and data
like other types of education
contributes to wealth inequality and
abuses of justice because it's not
distributed equally without education
which often translates into money and
power people can become vulnerable to
abuses of the system these are two
organizations that can help connect
technologists to justice involve
students who want to learn the code
cooperative operates a lot like a
bootcamp and works with formerly
incarcerated people in New York and the
last mile has technologists go into a
prison to teach concepts to people or
serving time that's in California you
can help people get good jobs mind work
jobs so that they have more power over
their own lives when so much has been
taken from them and at the same time you
can learn about the reality of prisons
and prisoners and help our entire
country you can communicate what you
learn to friends co-workers strangers
and legislators you can use this hotline
which will ask for your zip code and
then connect you to all your
representatives one after another put
this in your phone I always hear people
saying to call your representatives and
this hotline makes it extremely easy you
can contribute to it too since it's an
open-source project created in June of
2016 its affiliated with stay woke or an
organization that help that develops
multiple open-source tools that you can
also check out that link doesn't really
help you but you can search github or
call Congress I'm stable Korg everybody
got the phone number
great ok here's a list of organizations
that you can investigate in your own
time there are so many other individual
projects books court watches Town Hall's
efforts local to different cities people
have even mined cryptocurrency to raise
money for bail funds which is cool
because crypto so far has seemed to
disproportionately benefit the extremely
wealthy you can check out bail block by
the new inquiry later if you're
interested in that technology is a part
of the system it's not going away we've
seen how it goes wrong and it goes wrong
when creators don't care or aren't aware
of other tools affect people's lives
because it doesn't seem to affect their
lives these are the two options
technology can magnify
existing problems or it can help change
course the criminal legal system is not
closed there are no closed systems and
software when we build we have a
responsibility to seek out those hard to
hear stories and understand the context
of the data that often drives software
decision making no one person can
observe a system perfectly and the
people who've suffered from bad designs
need to be involved first in developing
solutions everyone in this room cares
you were drawn to this presentation
instead of the other options that were
available so I really hope that you talk
to each other I hope that you share
ideas and perspectives and I hope that
you help the world and help the country
and that's a yes that's a Booklist those
are all great books that's all I have
for now I don't I don't actually know
how I'm doing on time probably bad
yeah pretty bad ok you can see after a
few questions
[Applause]